what exactly is prime
factorization to understand this we just
need to understand two things first
prime numbers and second
factors let us understand factors first
consider a random number say 12 to get
its factors we just need to write 12 as
a product of two numbers in all the
possible ways it can be written as three
* 4 it can also be written as 2 * 6 is
that it don't forget the easier product
the product of one with the number
itself there is no other way in which 12
can be written as a product of two
positive
integers it means 1 2 3 4 6 and 12 are
the factors of
12 now that we know what factors are
let's move on to the second concept the
concept of prime
numbers we will look at a few numbers
and understand if they are prime or not
let's start with a number two think of
different ways in which two can be
written as a product of two positive
integers there's only one way it can be
written as 1 multiplied
2 such numbers which have only two
factors one and itself are called prime
numbers so we write a two here
what about the number three the only way
in which it can be written is 1
multiplied by 3 the product of one and
the number itself three also is a prime
number what about the number four it can
be written as 1 multiplied by 4 does
that mean it is a prime number hang on a
moment it can also be written as 2 * 2
as the number four has factors other
than one and itself it is not a prime
number the number five can only be
written as 1 multiplied by 5 which is
why five is a prime number six is not a
prime number seven is a prime number
eight and nine are not prime numbers and
that's how the list
progresses you know what prime numbers
mean you also know what factors mean so
now you can easily see what prime
factors mean it's simple factors of a
number which are Prime look at the
factors of the number 12 it has two
prime factors two and three so what does
prime factorization mean it means
writing a number as a product of its
prime
factors writing 12 as 2 * 2 * 3 is prime
factorization of
12 it is written as a product of its
prime
factors
[Music]